For the next metal to reuse hit time,
let's revisit the relationship between
the associativity and hit time.
So if we have high associativity in the
cache, we will have fewer conflicts for
the set in the cache when multiple
blocks go to the same set.
Which leads to a lower miss rate.
And that, we like.
With high associativity we have just
seen, we can build larger, virtually,
index physically, type caches,
which reduces the miss rate, and so
we like that too.
But high associativity
leads to slower hits.
The hit time goes up,
and that we don't like.
On the other hand, if we go all
the way to direct mapped caches,
the miss rate goes up for
these two reasons, and that is bad.
But the hit time is reduced, because a
direct mapped cache has only place where
a block can be, so we can quickly
check whether it's there or not.
And we like that.
So we can see that high associativity in
our cache improves the miss rate, but
makes the hit time worse.
While simple direct mapped caches,
sacrifice the miss rate
to improve hit time.
So now we will see if
we can get this and
this simultaneously,
by kind of cheating associativity.